question. Can you explain to me again why cancer patients should it take metal supplements?
I nature path things that I should since I have the MTHFR defect. So you have a lot of genes
that we look at and your MTHFR gene is one of them. So that's the metal tetrahedral folate
reductase gene is what that stands for. So that gene is at the end of the folate cycle. It takes
five methylene THF and breaks it down into ultimately to go into the methionine cycle which
at the end of that you know goes into the glutathione cycle. So it is important to have your genes
functioning. But even if I have a double allele defect on my most important MTHFR gene which is the
C677 gene it doesn't mean that I should be on methyl groups. So again when the genetics were first
looked into the MTHFR gene was one of the first and more research genes. And when genetic tests
first came out practitioners you know there wasn't a whole lot known about them but it was known
that people with MTHFR gene defects may have a more difficult time what was termed as methylating
meaning helping break down the folate cycle to go into the methionine cycle. So then it was thought
that everybody with an MTHFR gene defect has deficiencies in methyl groups so you should give them
methyl groups. You should give them methyl tetrahedral folate that's the type of folate that you
should be giving these people. And you should be giving them methyl comolomy that's a type of B12 you
should be giving these people. And there could be dangers of that because we've learned a whole lot
since since that was first discovered 15 years ago. And there's a lot more genes to look at. That's
one of the issues that I have with a lot of these gene companies that just do little snippets like
they might do 25 genes here and tell you whether you have difficulty losing weight or 25 genes here and
tell you if you have issues with methylation because your body doesn't work that way. It doesn't work
in little pieces. It doesn't work in little compartments. Your whole folate pathway feeds into your
methionine pathway which then feeds into your transulfiration pathway and feeds into your biopterant
pathway. And they're all functioning in this perfect chemistry or you could say this giant orchestra.
So just because we have an issue with one tuba player doesn't mean that we have to go and get
five new tuba players to play it. It's going to throw the whole symphony off. So you have to look
at the big picture when you're going to recommend supplementation based upon genetics. That's number one.
So number one, I would never tell a person because they have an MTHFR gene defect that you need to be
on methylated supplements. That's just wrong because if you put them on methylated supplements and you
didn't look at, let's say, the biopterant pathway and you didn't know that they also have
MAOA defects in the biopterant pathway and you add methyl groups. It will push that MAOA gene.
If they have defects in that they will spill out a lot of serotonin and they will have excess serotonin
and they could have range issues and all sorts of moon disorders to go back to neurobalances,
neurochemical and balances due to moon disorders can be because of something like that. So I've seen
this time and time again where a person was told because of one gene defect that you need to be on this
product and therefore it could tip over the whole symphony. Little off track but the question was
why should a cancer patient not take methyl supplements? I just spoke to somebody today that was
diagnosed with cancer and was going to a different practitioner that practitioner had them on
multiple supplements that had methyl comolamine and methyl tetrahedral folate. Well the problem with
that is what you're going to ask what do methyl, so what do methyl groups do? So a methyl group
remember from chemistry is a carbon with three hydrogens and it attaches to something. So when
you're taking a supplement like methyl tetrahedral folate it's a methyl group attached to tetrahedral
folate so that is a form of folate. So taking a B12 is comolamine now you could take an attach to
methyl so it's methyl comolamine. You could take a track to hydroxyl or a genocidal attach to
other organic compounds or you could have taken a attach to methyl. What's the advantage of that
methyl group? Well that methyl group will break off when you absorb that and it will be distributed
through your body and it will attach to different things and it has purposes. So you need methyl groups
I'm not saying that but would we take excess methyl groups? What do methyl groups do? Well methyl groups
will attach to your DNA and will turn genes off. Well we do need that. We do need genes turned off but
when we have excess methyl groups when we have a diagnosis of cancer when we have excess methyl groups
in the cell we can be turning off tumor suppressor genes. Remember one way that you kill cancer is that
you have this inside the cell. You have this component that God created that when you have cancer and
that cell is it in rapid replication that cell will signal the tumor suppressor system and your
tumor suppressor system will turn on to destroy the cancer from the inside out. That's called the
intrinsic apoptonic pathway. It stimulates this capsaic reaction and it kills the cell
destroyed it through apoptosis from the inside out and that's how you're protected from getting a
cancer diagnosis if you don't have one. So and when you have cancer that's one way that you will
kill the cell and destroy cancer from the inside out. It's that intrinsic apoptonic pathway
and it's hindered by you having excess methyl groups intracellularly. How would you have that
by taking too many methyl supplements that in fact there's some chemotherapies that the way they work
is they blocked the methylation pathway so that you're not producing excess methyl groups in the cell
so that you're helping and you're allowing the natural intrinsic apoptonic pathway to take place
by the stimulation of tumor suppressor genes and you're helping kill cancer. So a cancer patient
should not be taking methylated supplements unless we're dealing with other comorbidities.
As a person could have a comorbidity of elevated homocysteine and the way you bring down a homocysteine
is with by using methyl groups for a period of time but if you don't have elevated homocysteine
you should not be taking methyl groups as a cancer patient. Hopefully that helps. I do have some other
lectures on that to help understand that but I think I spoke too much.